I've been testing Korean skincare
products I've seen recommended again and
again by influencers I couldn't fit them
all into one video so here is part two
it's Michelle of loudmouth and Beauty
science chemistry PhD and cosmetic
chemist Korean skincare products are
super popular but there are so many
options it can be really overwhelming
how do you work out which products to
buy ingredient lists are helpful but any
cosmetic chemist will tell you you can't
judge how well a product works just from
that every chocolate cake has pretty
much the same ingredients but this one
tastes like Broken Dreams and
disappointment the ingredient list can
give you an idea of what to expect if
you know what you're looking for but it
doesn't replace testing it on actual
skin so I always check reviews on forums
but also from influences I trust
especially if they have similar skin to
mine today I'll be adding my thoughts on
these products and hopefully give you
some useful ingredient insights as well
these products are all available from
this video sponsor star Korean there's a
discount code in the caption too I'm
going to start with the skin food Royal
Honey propolis in Rich Essence this is a
long time favorite in the Korean
skincare Community it's been recommended
by so many people Kelly Driscoll James
Welsh Leah you Bonnie Garner Ben Neely I
was initially a bit iffy about an active
product from Skin Food I've loved their
pineapple peeling gel for a long time
but a lot of skin food products seem
kind of gimmicky with this food and
natural theme as someone who got into
skincare in the Pinterest stage I have a
bit of a
reaction to that this is the first
active product I tried from Skin Food
it's pretty multifunctional it's made
for hydrating and supporting the Skin
Barrier but it's also meant to help with
breakouts as well as plump and firm Skin
So targeting mature skin the key
ingredient is black bee propolis extract
propolis is B glue it's used to seal up
holes in hives it's made from plant sap
and it has some interesting properties
it's been investigated for use in wounds
in skin care it seems to be good for
soothing helping with breakouts and as a
source of antioxidants specifically it
has polyphenols and flavonoids skin
Foods propolis is double fermented to
make it more concentrated there are two
other B ingredients in this there's
royal jelly which has skin smoothing
properties and fermented aged honey all
of these are natural ingredients so the
specific substances in them and their
concentrations depend on lots of
different factors the species of beer
what they eat the season house extract
did and processed so for these sorts of
ingredients I always recommend looking
at reviews of specific products and
ignoring things like dupes and
percentages that's not super helpful I
found this Essence incredibly hydrating
which is exactly what I expected as well
as the beer extracts which all have
really hydrating components there's also
beta glucan this is a long chain sugary
molecule that's really good at holding
onto water and acting as a humectant
it's similar to hyaluronic acid there is
also hyaluronic acid and glycerin which
are both also humectants holding water
onto skin it also has purslane extract I
am not even going to try to pronounce
that I can do chemistry names but
Botanical names that is a skill tree I
have not filled out this is a herb
that's used in traditional Korean
medicine to help with irritated skin
there are also some ferments which can
have hydrating soothing and exfoliating
effects these were added into this newer
enriched version along with more
propolis excitingly for people who can't
handle niacinamide this does not have
niacinamide it's a bit of an older
product that was released before that
big niacinamide boom it's also fragrance
free and has a slightly sweet smell
people with sensitive skin have
generally said that their skin doesn't
react to this in terms of texture this
is silky and hydrating it's like a thick
sort of water not as thin as a toner but
not as thick as a proper serum it sinks
into my skin really quickly and it isn't
as tacky as I expected for something
that hydrates so well the most
impressive effect I've seen on my skin
with this is that it's been really good
at smoothing out texture and giving me a
glow overnight it's almost like a
chemical exfoliant sort of effect but
without any irritational stinging it was
also really good at calming down reddish
breakouts I had it layers nicely under
products too I'm actually wearing it
under my makeup right now but I think it
would be a bit sticky for daytime wear
if it's really humid I really like the
packaging of this too it's a glass
bottle with this gradient effect and
it's heavy enough at the bottom bottom
that I haven't knocked it over yet there
is also this nice button on top that you
press to fill up the dropper it's summer
here and I've been using this on its own
as my only product at night including
when I've got the aircon on and it's
been really good at preventing my skin
from drying out I'm sure I'll have to
add a moisturizer too when it gets
colder and drier overall I love this it
is going into my rotation skim 104
Madagascar centella light cleansing oil
is wanna skim 104's most popular
products Sue Beauty and onioni both
raved about this cleansing holes and
balms are really popular in Korean skin
care you don't need to use an oil-based
cleanser to remove water resistant
makeup and sunscreen but I prefer using
them because it feels so relaxing to
massage it into my skin and see
everything mess up sometimes I like mess
a lot of cleansing oils and balms leave
a bit of residue on your skin and might
not get all of your makeup off so you
often need to follow up with a second
cleanser also called double cleansing
this cleansing oil is designed to wear
work on its own and when I tested it on
some water resistant products I didn't
need to use a second cleanser this has
centella in it which is good for
soothing skin and people have tried this
on irritated skin have said that it's
quite calming this also worked really
well for removing waterproof eyeliner it
didn't sting my eyes or leave them
blurry which sometimes happens with
cleansing oils and that blurriness is
almost always an issue with cleansing
balms I really like this pump bottle the
pump actually dispenses the right amount
of product really easily lately I've
been trying a few products that don't
dispense well out of their pumps the
product will just kind of leap over my
hand onto the floor so I have been
really appreciating this aspect the
things I don't really like about this
product are really just personal
preference things for me I don't really
like the scent it's kind of lemony and
citrus it comes from Bergamot Rose and
rose geranium I also just prefer
cleansing balms over cleansing oils
because I find these a bit tricky to get
onto my face without dripping I really
don't like cleaning up oil drips if
you're looking for a cleansing oil
especially one that you can use on your
eyes or one that doesn't need to be
followed up with a second cleanser then
I think this is a fantastic option next
is the dumaso all-day vitamin
brightening and balancing serum I've
seen this recommended by tons of people
including Cassandra bankson Tina Tanaka
Harris uni and mishmus this is a serum
that's based around sea Buffalo fruit
extract which they use as like the water
source for this product they call it
vitamin tree because it contains a lot
of vitamins mainly vitamin C but also e
and K it also has a lot of antioxidant
and humectant compounds on top of that
this serum has added humectants like
glycerin and hyaluronic acid two percent
niacinamide some other beneficial plant
extracts panthenol and additional
ascorbic acid I found that this was
really hydrating and lightweight it
sinks in quickly and layers nicely under
sunscreen and makeup it didn't irritate
my skin at all and it has a nice Light
Citrus scent with none of that metallic
kind of smell you usually get with
ascorbic acid products but I didn't
notice any of the beneficial effects I
usually see with vitamin C like faster
brightening of acne marks I think here's
where I went wrong I didn't check the
Brand's own recommendations this is
their beginner vitamin C they have two
stronger options which probably would
have been more suitable for me as
someone whose skin really likes vitamin
C A lot of people do have issues with
vitamin C in the form of ascorbic acid
in their products these products can be
really irritating and cause breakouts
especially if they have a low PH that
low PH isn't always necessary for
ascorbic acid to get into skin and work
there are other ways to get it into skin
even with water-based products so this
serum might be good for you if your skin
is super sensitive to vitamin C you want
something budget friendly and you're
okay if it is mostly just hydrating with
any vitamin C action as an added bonus
but if your budget stretches a bit more
and you're specifically looking for a
vitamin C product I would recommend
looking for a product that has more
ascorbic acid but is still formulated to
be gentle next is the punkyang yo
calming moisture repair balm I love it
I'm sorry for that spoiler I can't hold
back this is just awesome I talked about
pyong Kang yo last time they're a brand
that uses a lot of traditional Korean
medicinal ingredients they won't have
got the misters favorite Brands and the
essence toner was nice but it didn't fit
into my routine that well I don't see
many people talking about this bomb
except Sue Beauty and Tina Tanaka Harris
maybe it gets lost amongst all of pky's
other moisturizers they also have a
cream in a jar that looks pretty much
the same with a very similar name that
costs less for more products so I think
maybe people tend to just skip over this
I tried this by chance and I am so glad
I did so my usual product for when my
Skin's irritated is the lorage per se
zika plus bum B5 I've talked about it a
lot when I went to Europe I knew I would
be buying the new B5 plus so I put this
in my hand luggage instead to help with
dry skin on the plane I mostly just put
it in there because it is so small and I
didn't really expect that much from it
it was just meant to tide me over this
is brilliant as you'd expect it has a
lot of the standard soothing barrier
support actives like panthenol and
centella there's also Honeysuckle and
tea tree extracts but no niacinamide it
also works really well for softening
those stiff dry flakes that I tend to
get when I've blown my nose too much the
magic with this product is the texture
the big issue with the sticker plus balm
is that the texture is just not great
it's thick and paste like and that is
fine at night but if you try to wear it
during the day especially with sunscreen
or makeup then it becomes a bit of a
greasy slidy mess this calming moisture
repair bomb has a thickish texture and I
expected it to be a bit gooey and sticky
like a lip balm but this just Glides on
so smoothly and sinks into skin really
quickly a little does go a long way with
this and you can apply a really thin
even layer without any hugging I've also
used a thicker layer overnight when it
felt like my whole face just needed that
extra nurturing it is heavier than most
Korean moisturizers which tend to be
super lightweight but compared to even a
western moisturizer for oily skin this
is just so weightless and refreshing but
even though it's light it still feels
like you have a protective layer on your
skin or like a layer that's merged with
the top layers of your skin it isn't
greasy or oily or slidy and it actually
has a matte finish if you don't apply
too much it almost feels like a
silicone-based moisturizer but it
actually doesn't have silicones in it it
has a lot of lightweight emollients like
squalene and sunflower oil and there's
also shea butter there are also lots of
humectants in it that keep water on your
skin like glycerin butane and a bunch of
different sizes of hyaluronic acid
having those different sizes I found
tends to be more effective for giving me
longer lasting hydration there are also
these two peptides in it which can
smooth and firm skin but I didn't really
see that happening when I was using it
because I was too busy focusing on my
skin not falling off my face I haven't
tried this much in cold dry weather yet
so it'll be interesting to see if my
skin does need a second moisturizer
weather but so far this has been an
absolute dream product I hope you
enjoyed chatting skincare with me you
might also like this video on sunscreens
let me know what you thought about these
products hit the like and the Subscribe
and comment to tell the algorithm to
give you more of this kind of video and
in the meantime happy skincare nerding